we have introduced the concept of
expected value or mean which tells us
the average value of a random variable
we will now introduce another quantity
the variance which quantifies the spread
of the distribution of a random variable
so consider a random variable with a
given PMF for example like the PMF shown
in this diagram and consider another
random variable that happens to have the
same mean but its distribution is more
spread out so both random variables have
the same mean which we denote by mu and
which in this picture it would be
somewhere around here however the second
PMF the blue PMF has typical outcomes
that tend to have a larger distance from
the mean by distance from the mean we
what we mean is that if the result of
the random variable it's numerical value
happens to be let's say for example this
one then this quantity here is X minus
mu is the distance from the mean how far
away the outcome of the random variable
happens to be from the mean of that
random variable of course the distance
from the mean is a random quantity it is
a random variable its value is
determined once we know the outcome of
the experiment and the value of the
random variable what can we say about
the distance from the mean let us
calculate its average or expected value
the expected value of the distance from
the mean which is this quantity using
linearity of expectations is equal to
the expected value of X minus the
constant mu but the expected value is by
definition equal to MU and so we are
then zero so we see that the average
value of the distance from the mean is
always zero and so it is uninformative
what we really want is the average
absolute value of the distance from the
mean or something with this flavor
mathematically it turns out that the
average of the squared distance from the
mean is a better behaved mathematical
object and this is the quantity that we
will consider it has a name it is called
the variance and it is defined as the
expected value of the squared distance
from the mean the first thing to note is
that the variance is always non-negative
this is because it is the expected value
of non negative quantities how exactly
do we compute the variance the squared
distance from the mean is really a
function of the random variable X so it
is a function of the form G of X where G
is a particular function defined this
way so we can use the expected value
rule applied to this particular function
G and we obtain the following
so what we have to do is to go over all
numerical values of the random variable
X for each one calculate its squared
distance from the mean and weigh that
quantity according to the corresponding
probability of that particular numerical
value one final comment the variance is
a bit hard to interpret because it is in
the wrong units if Capital X corresponds
to meters then the variance has units of
meters squared a more intuitive quantity
is the square root of the variance which
is called the standard deviation it has
the same unit as the random variable and
captures the width of the distribution
let us now take a quick look at some of
the properties of the variance we know
that expectations have a linearity
property is this the case for the
variance as well not quite
instead we have this relation for the
variance of a linear function of a
random variable let us see why it is
true we use the shorthand notation mu
for the expected value of x we will
proceed one step at a time and first
consider what happens to the variance if
we add the constant to a random variable
so let Y be X plus some constant B and
let us define mu to be the expected
value of y which using linearity of
expectations is the expected value of x
plus B let us now calculate the variance
by definition the variance of Y is the
expected value of the distance squared
of Y from its mean now we substitute
because in this case Y is equal to X
plus B whereas the mean mu is mu plus B
and now we notice that this B cancels
with that B and we are left with the
expected value of X minus mu squared
which is just the variance of X so this
proves this relation for the case where
a is equal to 1 the variance of X plus B
is equal to the variance of X so we see
that when we add a constant to a random
variable the variance remains unchanged
intuitively adding a constant just moves
the entire PMF right or left by some
amount but without changing its shape
and so the spread of this PMF remains
unchanged
let us now what happens if we multiply a
random variable by a constant let again
mu be the expected value of y and so in
this case by linearity this is equal to
a times the expected value of X so it is
a times mu we calculate the variance
once more using the definition and
substituting in the place of Y what Y is
in this case it's a X and subtracting
the mean of Y which is a mu squared we
take out a factor of a square and then
we use linearity of expectations to note
that this is a square times expected
value of X minus mu squared which is a
squared times the variance of X so this
establishes this formula for the case
where B equals 0 putting together these
two facts if we multiply a random
variable by a the variance gets
multiplied by a
where it and if we add the constant the
variance doesn't change and this
establishes this particular fact as an
example the variance of let's say three
minus four X is going to be equal to
minus four squared times the variance of
X which is 16 times the variance of X
finally let me mention an alternative
way of computing variances which is
often a bit quicker we have this useful
formula here we will see later a few
examples of how it is used but for now
let me just show why it is true we have
by definition that the variance of X is
the expected value of X minus mu squared
now let us rewrite what is inside the
expectation by just expanding this
square which is 2 minus mu X plus mu
squared using linearity of expectations
this is broken down into expected value
of x squared minus the expected value of
2 times mu X but mu is a constant so we
can take it outside the expected value
and we're left with 2 mu expected value
of X plus mu squared but remember that
mu is just the same as the expected
value of X so what we have here is twice
the expected value of x squared plus the
expected value of x squared and that
leaves us just minus the expected value
of X
squared so we will now move in the next
segment into a few examples of variance
calculations